exactly I have a guest I have Maxim VRA
here with me Maxim welcome to the show
you just made a draw against wesle so
with black pieces are you happy with
your result first of all yeah I'm happy
but at the same time when the opening
came on one end I was uh happy because
uh I knew I was going to play G6 and
it's very uh double edged but also
probably uh decent for black but at the
same time I was kicking my a bit cuz I
did recheck it this morning but I didn't
pay as much attention as I should have
and
um yes you also played it with white so
how is it sometimes to play the same
position with some black and white
pieces you know yeah with night of it
happens all the time all the time but uh
yeah I didn't mind I played with white a
lot of times but this G6 and queen B6 is
uh I wouldn't say new but uh it's still
relatively unexplored compared to the
main movie five mhm I see so let's say I
mean the game was developing quite
logically of course you never can take
on B2 no I just can show one detail so
after Queen B6 if white goes A4 okay so
now you don't go Knight C6 because take
on C6 but you go Bishop G7 and if white
goes A5 no you can take you can take
Bishop B ah and then you defend your
queen yes that's a trick yes okay
so A4 was not good A3 he played I mean
it's not that A4 is not good but like
you don't need to play A5 is definitely
not
good uh so yeah of course Knight H6 is
another option but Knight G3 uh is very
principled and yeah that's I didn't
remember if I should go Bishop B6 or if
I should start Bishop G7 Castle um but
in the end I decided this position was
um quite playable once I get D5 I assume
them not
worse um I was wondering somewhere here
let's say instead of Bishop H6 there was
so many options like what do you
normally do you Castle long you Castle
short you you will do you will do H4 H5
is this yes also was possible yes but H4
I go H5 uhhuh if Castle King side then
I'm up just Castle King and if long
Castle I think this was critical uh
Castle short side okay yes and then
maybe it can be some yeah but you go B5
B4 some Knight D4
play three years yeah I couldn't
remember the details which is why I was
not happy with myself but okay uh no
this I remembered after Bishop B2 you
you don't care you give the
pawn something
like maybe B5 B5 yes and the queen6 just
que A5 I could say it sorry say it of
course yes something like this I I'm not
really sure but uh I knew this should be
okay this it could be completely
different game yes if he would have
played this long castle with oppos
course but even here I felt there's lots
of play uh but maybe I'm the one who
bail out with D5 like I can go King B8
Knight to D4 Rook C8 or even here start
with Knight D4 and Rook C8 but I
felt I don't know I felt it shouldn't be
better for
me and so I just decided to go for D5
and I mean there's still some
things going on here I thought uh can
become very tricky for white but Bishop
D knight2 was nice especially Knight E2
I didn't see yeah so he's maybe maybe
F5 but here I don't have time and for
instance F6 would be ill advised up take
oh Bishop G6 yes look scary but mhm uh
Pawn is a pawn yeah but don't like to
give them a I was thinking maybe you
could have avoided this Knight exchange
and go with your knight back to C6 or
yeah I didn't want to but but and that
something is different no I mean of
course Knight F5 was my idea but Bishop
takes yes um Pawn takes I assum I'm
slightly worse and Bishop takes Knight
C3 the queen on H6 especially is
unpleasant now because I always eting at
H7 maybe Queen G7 sometimes sometimes G4
and this Knight is not worse than to
Bishop for sure yeah so at the end let's
say there was just dra repetition and
the game finished the draw what do you
think about actually this rule with ch
was long for a long time here no draw
offers I don't mind uh I mean we play
until natural conclusion and anywhere in
anal position we are very creative in
finding move repetitions exactly I was I
was wondering because I didn't see you
after this rapid and Blitz championship
of course I mean this crazy last game
like um let's say what were your
emotions after and what did you do after
the end of the
tournament well I mean first I had toar
Fabian who told me that he didn't tell
me that he didn't see me really think
that famous uh Rook move yes so I went
back to my hotel room
actually uh because of the delay I I I
arrived around the moment that I did
Drop The Rook yes so I at least you know
like you knew that this is what really
happened like I I knew because uh I lost
connection let's say yeah some so I drop
the book I take it back immediately and
then in my brain it's like for one
second did I did I release it and I was
pretty sure I released yes anyway the
Arbiter saw me release so like Chris
B even if I liked all sense of fair play
uh I would have been you know brought
brought back to reason but of course uh
it was pretty sad and but I don't think
this was a game that cost me the the
tournament for sure uh I did get this
opportunity of course but I think of
course the first two ones which I lost
were not great MH and then there were
many games where I was uh uh better SL
winning that I didn't TN with white
against Ray actually this yes yes
against free especially this two and I
mean this could have changed things
quite a bit in any case I mean still it
was great event you know just finished
two days three days ago and now we have
singfield cup all the best of luck for
you Maxim we just started only two
rounds uh we have and all the best of
luck for you tomorrow yeah thank Youk
you thank you Anastasia thank you